je veux dénoncer un scandale un vol un
raquette organisé avec en plus la
facilité de l'État
[Musique]
électricité égale près
d'abord ressources de nouvelles offres
on passerait de 15 euros du mégawatt
pour le gaz à
240 euros soit une multiplication par 16
du prix et pour l'électricité on
passerait de 65 euros du mégawatt à 2068
euros le prix serait donc multiplié par
32 à l'échelle de toute la ville on
passerait de 2 millions d'euros de
factures d'énergie à 10 12 ou 15
millions d'euros au global et qu'est-ce
qui se passerait si on refusait de
signer ces offres totalement délirantes
au 1er novembre on nous couperait
l'électricité et le gaz pour notre ville
de près de 40 000 habitants
un bol un raquette organisé avec en plus
la possibilité de les plans
facteurs sont contents
[Musique]
et
moi recherche de nouvelles offres
qui dans l'entreprise pour ne soigner
nos réponses on est donc aujourd'hui
une partie
[Musique]
c'est totalement inacceptable mais
malheureusement le gouvernement laisse
faire
[Musique]